[Applaus]
[Musik]
bewegende geschichten sind nicht selten
durch außergewöhnliche ereignisse
geprägt so auch diese
zeitlebens war sepp ein bergbauer mit
leib und seele doch jetzt hindert ihn
sein körper geliebte arbeit ist so qual
geworden
die show wird ich hoffe ich hoffe
ja robert zemeckis machen und aber
die familie sucht eine lösung damit es
mit dem ruf irgendwie weitergeht
[Musik]
ist ein bauer wie sein vater einer war
auch der großvater und der urgroßvater
heute kann der familien betrieben oder
und mit hilfe der kinder aufrecht
erhalten werden der bergbauer hofft dass
eines von ihnen den hof übernehmen wird
noch ahnt er nicht dass dieser wunsch
für die familie zur zerreißprobe wird
dieser film spielt vor der grandiosen
kulisse des materials im kanton uri das
tal zählt zu den wildesten gegenden der
schweizer alpen und liegt auf der
nordseite des gotthard massivs
in den wintermonaten fällt kein
sonnenstrahl auf den kleinen bauernhof
ein schatten scheint sich aber auch über
die familie gelegt zu haben
während den fast 20 jahren drehzeit
stellt sie das leben immer wieder auf
die probe
[Musik]
das material natal eine raue alpenwelt
die naturgewalten sind nah und spürbar
im winter führt der schulweg von selbst
kindern marian silvia und marcel mitten
durchs lawinengebiet
vorjahren donnerten die schneemassen bis
ins wohn ja selbst bis ins kinderzimmer
hinein
[Musik]
ich denke wir sind der klare 6
es ist von der sitte heimat
und deutschland standen
sogar
ich stark erhöht
der januar ist ein monat in dem viele
wohl am liebsten verreisen möchten aus
dem weiler der 900 meter über meer liegt
doch die familie app bleibt trotz aller
naturgefahren die drohen
im februar stürzt eine gewaltige lawine
auf den weiler nur gerade ein steinwurf
vom hof entfernt kommen die schneemassen
zum stehen
am morgen danach die familie ist wohlauf
doch das atelier ist von der umwelt
abgeschnitten
also die brücke dass er das trotz krise
die durch die hre mitgeteilt das land
tief im schnee
also war der mann war von der wucht das
hätte sind doch nur aktive lacht die
flecken
eigene sowie die verehrte
damals aus mainz hat mir nach hause
zu bleiben
aber am besten wenn man nach wie vor
höchst beliebt und ja aber war es
wirklich nur ein nasses
passiert
[Musik]
in diesen engen tal abschnitt ziehen
2005 zwei neue bewohner innen ein die
fünfjährige tamara und maria app kurz
danach gibt es zuwachs maria die
zufälligerweise den gleichen nachnamen
hat kam als haushälterin
name ist ja
richtig
dass
das ist jetzt kein
familien
an diesem nachmittag hat marcel
schulfrei
selbstverständlich hilft er seinem vater
bei der arbeit
in seine fußstapfen möchte der 13
jährige aber nicht treten er glaubt dass
man als bergbauer bei den frauen keine
chance habe
[Musik]
marcel und seine beiden schwestern maria
und sylvia wuchsen praktisch ohne ihre
leibliche mutter auf
[Gelächter]
schon 1998 hat seine damalige frau ihn
und die gemeinsamen kinder verlassen
und
behindert und horst krieg ist das weiche
anitas
ich habe das schwierigste sei dank sich
mit drin das ist schon so ganz schwierig
sie nicht immer nur einfach los angeles
dazu hängen
nur wenige male in seinem leben hat der
bergbauer das material natal bisher
verlassen
eingebettet im steilen gelände liegt
sein wiesland ein fehltritt könnte
fatale folgen haben
zudem kann es jederzeit steine haben
was ist denn damit der nachbar passiert
dann sind streichen und
den
geliebten sicher dem sturm bei sich
eigentlich vorstellen für architektur im
winter an die lawinen steinschlag vor
dass ich würden untereinander wie vor
stabil schwierig so funktioniert das
sieht
ja
es ist schon wieder so wurde ich weiß
nicht ob wir ihm erinnerungen sich der
routinier aber wenn ich muss diese
verkehr
ist dass andere
junge fährt man mit der forderung
warnung
gegeben wir irgendwann begegnen
[Musik]
im juni ist alpaufzug
das familienoberhaupt führt den zug mit
den sieben kühen an so will es die
tradition
hinter den tieren folgt marcel
plötzlich hat schmerzen im knie
zum ersten mal in seinem leben übernimmt
marcel die führung
red muss im auto dem aufzug folgen
[Musik]
ja
das ziel ist die allee unterhalt des
rütli passes auf 1350 meter über meer
hier verbringen die kühe die nächsten
drei monate
[Musik]
die alt wird als genossenschaft geführt
selbst präsident der verschworenen
gesellschaft
die berger leben eng verbunden mit der
natur und ihren glauben
manche wo sich um die
um das verriet war dem absurd aber das
kennen
dies gab und der liebe jesus gleich viel
das was ihr mann ist
dies gut von böse stimmen
es war der gott und die liebe gottes und
allerheiligen
[Musik]
während es in den playoffs werden
im juli verbringt die familie ed viel
zeit auf ihren wiesland welches 15
hektaren umfasst
die kinder haben schulferien und packen
ohne murren und klagen mit an
[Musik]
er sicherte sich die russin nicht
dankbarer leisten was du da die frist
machte und
rankhilfen strange zu betreuen gehabt
und mir um meine mutter hat es gehakt
im sommer 2009 sieht unheil über dem akw
auf ein mordfall der in der innerschweiz
viel aufsehen erregt betrifft direkt die
familie app
der mord prozess findet im landrat zahl
von altdorf statt bei der mutmaßlichen
täterin handelt es sich um selbst
geschiedene ehefrau und mutter der
gemeinsamen kinder
nachdem sie die familie im atelier
verlassen hatte heiratete sie ein
drittes mal kurz danach soll sie ihren
neuen ehemann dr spritzen einer
überdosis insulin getötet haben
handfeste beweise gibt es keine und so
kommt es zu einem indizienprozess
das obergericht spricht die schuldig und
verurteilt sich zu neun jahren
freiheitsstrafe
selbst ex frau beteuert nach wie vor
ihre unschuld und reicht beschwerde beim
bundesgericht ein
marian marcel und sylvia besuchen im
september ihre mutter sie wurde aus der
haft entlassen weil das bundesgericht
urteil noch aussteht
tragischer app ist gebürtige serbin die
44-jährige war dreimal verheiratet sie
wohnt bei ihrer tochter aus erster ehe
die auch schon mutter ist
[Musik]
ja
dass sie
die gemeinsamen stunden könnten gezählt
sein sollte auch das bundesgericht
plagiats schuldig sprechen müsste sie
zurück ins gefängnis
das material an weihnachten 2009
während der feiertage erfahren die
kinder der familie app neues über ihre
mutter
[Musik]
regel aus leeds mit dem in
europa
kriegspräsident richtig das
bundesgericht stützt das urteil betrifft
das hat in frauenberger vorsätzlicher
tötung zu einem jahr freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt das bundesgericht werden
beschwerden klagte und vorgestellt
wird geschlossen
rund
um das haus erlebt dass das irgendwie
siebter vor weiß anita tack forderte ist
dass das die das theater angehörige
selbst am radio und
print ja
gar nicht
dass die frau auch noch hin dass es mehr
sicher erkennen die base und
witzig gute nachricht co das extra jetzt
tatsächlich verurteilt wurde ich vom
bundesgericht was denken sie da
wenn sie selbst gemachter ego zunahme
aber mehr denn einfach kindheit wo jetzt
eigentlich im ganzen schlamassel die
leidtragenden
weil sie keinen job von und machen und
schicksalsschläge musste er schon einige
verkraften er nahm sie hin ohne zu
klagen er findet seinen frieden bei der
arbeit mit den tieren viel verdient er
damit nicht
im jahr
also
um die gruppen dann dauert
daher nicht im kongo aber
nicht das metier ist ein jahresbudget
von netto 20000 franken das geht nur
dank selbstversorgung
[Musik]
nur julia die kleinste bekommt ein
geschenk
stifter eine stoffpuppe und ein malbuch
mehr liegt nicht drin
ich sagen da hin wenn ich muss so hat
manche ende eines
konzeptes mental austausch sich direkt
mich angezogen auch dann wenn es sich
nicht so kritisch
hmm
das medien fällt ihm zunehmend schwer
die hüfte schmerzt aber auch seine knie
und fußgelenke plagen ihn nur dank
schmerzmitteln kann er noch arbeiten
das heißt die probleme
in diesem sommer schwingt der bergbauer
zum letzten mal die sense bald wird er
erfahren dass seine gelenke aufgrund der
schweren arbeit massiv abgenutzt sind
den oktober verbringt er im spital
liestal
beide sprunggelenke wurden versteht
man sich
die
opposition
also die hält man sich zusammen
vorwärts lager
während der bergbau im spital liegt
bleibt viel arbeit an seiner
lebenspartnerin maria abhängen selbst
sagt die am telefon zwar was ist zu tun
gibt aber seine zukunftsängste behält er
für sich
ein heiliges verläuft wird sie und david
miles davis
all die vielen sorgen wachsen maria über
den kopf zieht sich ab diesem moment von
den dreharbeiten zurück nur noch in
seltenen fällen lässt sich filmen
[Musik]
einmal mehr war der bergbauer in spittal
frisch operiert kehrte nach hause zurück
[Musik]
zu den bereits früher versteiften
sprunggelenken erhielt dir auch noch
prothesen an beiden knien zudem wurde
ihm ein künstliches hüftgelenk
eingesetzt
während seiner abwesenheit regnete es
auf den maderanertal die gras ernte fiel
mager aus nun fehlt es an heu vorrat für
den winter selbst braucht zusätzliches
futter für die tiere für das nötige geld
muss sie eine kuh verkaufen
[Gelächter]
diese warnsignale geht nur
weil man oft sucht macht das hat mir
immer weiße weste freuen aber jetzt ist
erstmal egal wo sein möchte wenn das ist
nach
jedem der par franken hat man einen aber
ich nehme dir dahin der andere mal ja
[Musik]
ein halbes jahr ist vergangen seit
seinem letzten spitalaufenthalt noch
immer schmerzt ihn jeder schritt
er ist nicht mehr der bergbauer der er
einmal war sepp kann seiner geliebten
arbeit nicht mehr nachgehen wie gewohnt
schweren herzens entschließt er sich ein
paar weitere tiere zu verkaufen
der bergbauer wird die hoffnung aber
nicht aufgeben würde eines seiner kinder
den hof übernehmen könnte der
familienbetrieb weitergeführt werden
[Musik]
ein solcher hotel unic arbeitet seit
kurzem eine junge frau aus dem material
marian ist hier als rezeptionistin
angestellt parallel dazu besucht sie die
hotelfachschule das leben in der stadt
ist mit vielen neuen eindrücken
verbunden
vor allem oberland und hier schon alles
sagt er knapp
ihr herz hat sie nicht an zürich
verschenkt marians heimat bleibt das aha
natal
ein paar wochen später
im mai 2015 in der zürcher
hotelfachschule park
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich habe
alles fröhlich strahlende gesichter
gesehen das gehört sich natürlich auch
so wenn sie jetzt in ein paar wenigen
augenblicken hier wirklich verdient das
diplom entgegennehmen dürfen gratuliere
ihnen ganz ganz herzlich zu ihrem diplom
das strahlen in ihrem gesicht ist
eindeutig sie freuen sich auch alles gut
ist schön dass ich als ich
maria net part nach drei jahren
ausbildung die hotelfachschule davon
reich abgeschlossen
werden
person ab hervorheben das halte ich mich
heute ist bevor hilfen nein die sind zu
machen wir weiter dass maschinen
erreicht und das ist doch jetzt schon
mal ich hab doch etwas erreichen wollen
ihre nummer und ich will mir bis ich
habe das gemacht und ich
erzogen und hat
[Musik]
während marion im hotel arbeitet beginnt
im sommer 2015 ihr bruder marcel app
eine lehre als lastwagenchauffeur
noch fehlt ihm der fahrausweis deshalb
ist er meistens in der werkstatt des
transportunternehmens anzutreffen
da sagen ich wunderbar
ich hoffe ganz tagen aufstockerinnen und
30 kinder lernen und somit wieder sauber
geistig beschmiert die plastik auf die
straße das ist ständig zu unterschätzen
also wirklich
nach wie vor wohnt er bei seinem vater
in seine fußstapfen treten möchte masse
nicht aber der 19 jährige packt in jeder
freien minute auf dem hof mit an
der sommer geht dem ende entgegen
die bauern der genossenschaft von
dresden treiben ihre tiere von der alb
zurück in die ställe
[Musik]
den alpabzug sitzend am steuer
mitzuerleben ist für den 63-jährigen
schon fast zur gewohnheit geworden
[Musik]
mit seinen versteiften knöcheln und
künstlichen gelenken kann er nur noch
kurze strecken zu fuß gehen
an einer weggabelung werden die tiere
auf die einzelnen höfe aufgeteilt hier
trifft er auf die anderen bauern und
auch auf silvia und tamara
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dieser kleidung hilft die mich noch nie
[Musik]
das habe ich immer gemacht
er
war
wie es weitergehen soll mit dem
familienbetrieb wird zur zentralen frage
tamara ist mit ihren 14 jahren noch zu
jung dazu
[Musik]
sehen wir hat eine ausbildung als
pflegefachfrau abgeschlossen momentan
ist die 20-jährige auf stellensuche
imam ali sieht für sich keine große
zukunft
grundsätzlich als sehr gut und spüre
hier oben ich habe auch wenn allein ich
glaube verloren
also sich wirklich
voll mitzieht und sport einfach nicht
bald hat tamara die obligatorische
schulzeit hinter sich langsam muss sie
sich mit der berufswahl
auseinandersetzen
der bergbauer sieht sein lebenswerk
bedroht
die pension hunderte junger durch und
aus dem anderen jungen der spitze auf
das war das schönste aber keiner mehr
danach haben wir dann immer hoffen und
das ist ja der fertigung ja zuvor 16 8
die hofer übernahm war hier seine mutter
katharina abt bäuerin seit vier
generationen ist der hof in
familienbesitz
[Musik]
die strafanstalt hindelbank im kanton
bern
3g chip die mutter von marian silvia und
marcel wird entlassen von ihren neun
jahren haftstrafe musste sie deren sechs
absitzen
[Musik]
meine familie meine
ich diese freude bis zur wand
wiese tag kommen was ich da einfach sie
ab oder ich meine es ist geschafft
trotzdem sei das kapitel abschließen so
fries ist für die st der neffe kann man
sagen dass wir zusammen
tragisch hat laut bundesgerichtsurteil
ihrem dritten ehemann durch eine
überdosis insulin getötet
ja es ist schwierig zu sagen ob sie es
gemacht also das nicht aber
wenn sie es gemacht hat ist das ist so
und wenn
doch dann ist jetzt ja mit den sachsen
haus und hof selb ist mensch ist gemacht
hatte dass sie bis zum scanner dass man
merkte krawall gemacht
ja aber ich
glaube trotzdem nicht mit ja
im untergeschoss eines hauses im kanton
uri bezieht tragisch app eine
sozialwohnung die kinder haben die möbel
organisiert und die wohnung eingerichtet
der neuanfang erfüllt die 50-jährige mit
sorgen
ich
bin wirklich ich bin nie zur mensch ich
bin nicht machen ich werde mich tut weh
außerdem wegen ruft ich zeige mich
sicher nicht angestrahlt
was macht sie nicht geschockt
[Musik]
sap muss sich erholen eine starke grippe
machte ihn zum medizinischen notfall
sohn 18 hat extra ferien genommen um das
vieh zu versorgen
sein vater hat wieder ein paar tiere
dazu gekauft im stall müssen jetzt acht
kühe und acht kinder versorgt werden
marcel unterstützt seinen vater mit
gemischten gefühlen
[Musik]
ihr habt das ist
es nur gerecht wenn man sieht was man
brauchen
[Musik]
stefan roos ist ein 25 jähriger bauer im
luzernischen ruswil
er hat 20 kühe und lebt von der
milchwirtschaft
[Musik]
via facebook lernte er vor einem jahr
eine 23 jährige frau aus dem kanton uri
kennen seit ein paar monaten leben die
beiden gemeinsam auf dem hof unweit des
sempachersee
seine herzdame ist silvia
gerade musste sie ihre hüfte aufgrund
einer fehlbildung operieren lassen auf
dem hof mitzuhelfen ist ihr deshalb
nicht möglich
stefan ist das egal der bauer ist
einfach froh dass er sein glück gefunden
hat
das ist wichtig für
die große liebe ja wäre ich sehr liebe
auf den ersten blick
sind ja ich bin da halt da war indes
nicht
so einfach
aus aber sympathie und alles andere muss
man über
silja würde gerne wieder als
pflegefachfrau arbeiten aber ihre
gesundheit lässt das momentan nicht zu
dafür brachte sie bereits neuen schwung
in den betrieb sie eröffnete einen
kleinen hofladen
[Musik]
im zentrum von doro punkt vielleicht
wisst was ich gar nicht dass der hof
leider gibt es signalisiert
aber das ist ja
ja ja ausläuft
stefan hat den ruf von seinen eltern
gepachtet den vater sieht er nicht oft
das verhältnis zu ihm ist angespannt
silvia ist in ihrem neuen leben noch
nicht ganz angekommen
[Musik]
im achter lieb und seiner familie fühlt
sich auch stefan sehr wohl dass der
bergbauer den hof an die nächste
generation übergeben will weiß auch er
außerdem vorstellen mit serien mit sie
uns auch
jetzt nicht
damit
gibt es zur
ich werde gebraucht wie sie ja das mit
einem mast und bürgerrechtler
und
ja
[Musik]
tragischer app gibt ein abschiedsfest
die mutter von maria silvia und marcel
verlässt die schweiz sie zieht zu ihrem
neuen lebenspartner in den balkan
auch marcel kommt um seine mutter zu
verabschieden sie wird ihn so wie die
anderen kinder und enkelkinder aus
erster ehe nicht mehr häufig sehen
medienminister kaputt zu machen immer
mehr täglich machen immer und nach nimmt
man die schweiz aber ich bin also
sie findet dass das spanish das heißt
das so machen ich bin besser lernen aber
es ist ja noch gar nicht steht
[Musik]
bei silvia und stefan kündigen sich
veränderungen an
sie ist im dritten monat schwanger
so was geht vor foto
links weiß gar nicht was du willst
geburtstag ich mitreden muss zu uns
kennt
trotz zweier fehlgeburten ist die
23-jährige zuversichtlich dass diesmal
alles gut verlaufen wird
die vorfreude auf das kind wird
allerdings getrübt die finanzen des
hofes liegen in schieflage
[Musik]
bringen ja oder ja
beleuchtet das tiefste stand zählen am
stand
[Musik]
damit so
viel
und so genug und es leben heute macht
sich mittels cool wenn man noch
betrieb managen importe so läuft und
wenn ich das mal gespielt und das thalia
oder zusammen gemacht hat ja
vieles läuft nicht so wie gewünscht
beim gehen schmerz die operierten hüfte
noch immer auch eine stelle hat sie ja
noch nicht gefunden
zudem bleibt die kundschaft im hofladen
weiterhin aus
hoffentlich
existenzkampf für die tore ja
also ich aber kaum machen wenn man
frisch verliebt ich stell mir das ganze
nicht so dass ich etwas vergangen bis
ich auf eine marine harvest daher läuft
und kartelle vom da die haut johanna
leder und
amanda umstrukturieren und machen
[Musik]
marian verbringt diesen sommer jede
freie minute in weiler 8 oberhalb von
dresden die 27 jährige führt den hof
ihres vaters praktisch im alleingang und
das nebst ihrem 100 prozent job im
gastgewerbe
[Musik]
für mich gemacht will wenn ich sitzen
immer hat die wirtin regale und ja es
war die neue haupt oder unten nicht
diese verschiedenen schriften und es
geht ihr wieder andere und eben der
schlaue lässig und 16 wird sorgen
die vorfreude auf das kind will silvia
mit ihrem vater teilen
selbst wird zum ersten mal großvater er
nimmt es gelassen das sei der lauf des
lebens sie
aus manchen
sogar dahin kann und dann begannen sie
haben sich die radltour nein der immer
einen gewissen der hand des ermessens
stoppte der und wenn wir jetzt nur seine
oder 18 20 xi wang
erwartet das problem
was ist das
aber selbst
[Gelächter]
die nachlese ich weiß ja nicht
[Musik]
umsonst
heißt der beschlüsse da sein ich das
alles noch ein schuh frachter hatte man
kind im haus
also wo also jährigen bay rejects grüßen
und ja aber
ich weiß dass ich schon einfach
der ema200 sich doch nur eins nämlich
ein akku aus
[Gelächter]
also ist für mich verschiedene
chronische
das transportunternehmen baldini in
altdorf
[Musik]
die
forschungsstelle parkplatz
tamara app ist im zweiten lehrjahr als
lastwagenfahrerin
noch darf sie nur auf dem gelände der
firma fahren
[Musik]
ursprünglich wollte tamara eine
kochlehre machen nun habe sie ihren
traumberuf gefunden sagt die 18 jährige
es hat ziemlich sonst lebt machen
aber sicherlich aber
es ist ein traum
seit tamara in der lehre ist lebt sie in
altdorf
[Musik]
zusammen mit marcel gründete sie eine wg
er hat seine lehre inzwischen
erfolgreich abgeschlossen
heute ist silvia zu besuch
eigentlich wäre es nun zeit für das
abendessen
hoch steht es noch
karten
es ist eigentlich mit dem original das
habe nichts deutsche sind gleich nicht
wieso ich konnte jetzt die adresse
korrekt
eigentlich schlecht
gestaunt haben die person konnte dank
venedig
gründen zu
suchen
ich habe schon nicht einfach erwartet
dass man im sommer ist man viel arbeit
also immer die ganz hoch himmel
unterwegs und das hat man für kritik und
arbeitet am samstagmorgen aufteilen und
nachher war dass man sie haben mit
leuten zu unterhalten
ja
[Musik]
der 28 dezember
für silvia und stefan ein bedeutender
tag soeben gaben sich die beiden auf dem
standesamt im luzernischen wolhusen das
ja wort
abschnitt
hat sich entschlossen haben
silvia ist im achten monat schwanger als
sie
schließlich in caracas dementierte dass
sich das klassische familienbild
mit dem
schluss dass es war aber sowie als 12
jahre planung setzt einfach nur witzig
vorzogen
ja aber sich eigentlich in meinem
herzenswunsch
die sorgen des alltags sind an diesem
tag weit weg
die größte wunsch für die zukunft
dass jedes jahr von milica führen und
dort sie und 16 formuliert wie das
ist ja das ist es glück wo man sich ein
käufer
der normalerweise allen veränderungen
gelassen gegenübersteht geht die heirat
seiner tochter nahe wir jetzt im moment
vertraulich erlaubt
bewegt ja ja
[Gelächter]
ja
die alpen oberhalb von airolo
marian hat ihre stelle in zürich
aufgegeben und ist wieder in die berge
gezogen
sie arbeitet nach wie vor im gastgewerbe
aber eigentlich schlägt ihr herz für die
landwirtschaft ein dilemma
aber dies kann in der heimat los und
einfach alles andere und solche mit raum
ist das verbinden gastronomie und
landwirtschaft geistlinger aber wer weiß
ich nicht viel machen
das landwirtschaftliche bildungszentrum
im urnerischen seedorf
die hotelfachschule hat sie schon
absolviert
nun besucht marian auch noch die
bauernschule
grund ist billig wo man noch machen wie
und
was nicht
[Musik]
er hoffe die machen
ja
das weiß ich habe nicht so richtig das
ist doch
momentan noch live wird die situation
wenn ich denke ich ein sehr ist er in
porto bei 10 euro und
darauf nun mut dazu alle war fast alle
sehr viel für mich für mich die
ausbildung dauert drei jahre
vielleicht hat sich bis dann die
situation geklärt mit etwas
unterstützung könne sie dann dass alle
übernehmen zudem spielt sie mit der idee
dort auch einen gastbetrieb zu eröffnen
seit dem 2 februar 2009 10 ist luisa auf
der welt so heißt die tochter von silvia
und stefan
doch jetzt anfangs märz liegt das baby
schwer krank im kinderspital luzern
ist ein blauer ford hätten immer
gescheiter moment und wenn ja wann ich
bin sofort mit ihrem spital und den
hätten sie das eigentlich neue karte ab
klagt ja
was sagen
langwierige geschichte
nimmt eine show mit das ist haupt aber
es ist die seite geschämt
ja ich bin jetzt mal täglich und vor
allem aber wird jetzt wirklichkeit die
sache nicht wirklich schwarze läufern
und ich hoffe dass sie wieder voll
gesund wird und
welche folgen
das hat priorität
während silvia die ganze zeit hindurch
im spital bei luisa bleibt stefan einmal
am tag vorbei
ja die sorgen um seinen hof und jetzt
die krankheit seiner tochter machen ihm
zu schaffen
ja ja
ja
auch die ersten
gäste bereits zum retter also die ganze
situation jugendraum ja
um sehen wir fast zum reden das ist gab
es bei männern um die person
die verhält wo man inzwischen
die höhe
[Musik]
damit dürften
die drückende hitze dieses sommertages
kostet die familie app manchen
schweißtropfen
der wintervorrat für die tiere muss in
den stall gebracht werden
marian ist inzwischen diplomierte
bäuerinnen wert die bauernschule mit
bestnoten abgeschlossen
[Musik]
auch die inzwischen elfjährige julia
packt mit an
spuren oder welche mal ist es anders
machen
ja auch eigentlich soviel ich weiß nicht
was du sagst aber schob er so reißt mich
wenn ich mal nicht ganz sicher
bedient den chrysler wegen seiner
angeschlagenen gesundheit muss er die
schweren arbeiten seinen kindern
überlassen
sie ist eine magische richtig aber mit
dem buch genannt mit kühlem acht wochen
machen
und ich mache also
nicht
verstehen wieso wird
nur weil die jungen mit anpacken kann
der bergbauer seinem betrieb noch
aufrechterhalten
volkswirt und seit
juni
diagnose loni männer zwar
[Musik]
schick war dass sich da die man immer
glücklich ist und länder dennoch sei es
oft ja ich heiße adidas auch eine plane
den japanischen sony corp
[Musik]
drei monate ist es her seit die kleine
luisa im spital war jetzt lebt die
kleine familie wieder vereint auf dem
hof im luzernischen ruswil
der stadt und
doch von einem unbeschwerten leben kann
keine rede sein der betrieb ist hoch
verschuldet stephan musste konkurs
anmelden
halt mir vorstellen das zeichen jemals
garten macht
ja es gibt keine möglichkeit dass
gleichen gebiete silvia ja
gerade ziemlich roja belauscht hat ja
schwer so sehr dass er
schlaflose nacht charakter ja die eine
viertelmillion franken schulden dazu
luisas krankheit nach ihrer geburt
silvia kann ich zurück in ihrem beruf
als pflegefachfrau wegen ihrer
hüftprobleme
lange zeit sagte er ihr nichts über
seine finanziellen probleme
beiden fehlt eine perspektive
er ist schwermütig und sie enttäuscht
die hat
ja eigentlich nur mit 220
unterstützung vorführung
hat es das fordert kommt habe ich gehe
das keine prophezeit dass es eine lösung
muss einfach sagen ja ich weiss nicht
einfache situation
wenn wenigstens sehen wir eine stelle
hätte dann könnte sie die finanzielle
situation etwas verbessern
die 24 jährige sucht sich hilfe bei esta
hofstetter von prokop die organisation
hilft unter anderem menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen bei der umschulung
lange kann sie ja nicht auf den beinen
stehen eine arbeit im sitzen wäre ideal
für sie
mit dem kauf habe ich muss
also kann man sich in die letzte option
und also alles andere vorher aber das
sozialpädagogisch
silvia fühlt sich eng verbunden mit den
tieren und der landwirtschaft am
liebsten würde sie bäuerin bleiben
[Musik]
marcel hat große pläne
er baut sich in altdorf ein geschäft auf
das wirkt danach fragen kann ich mich
büro auswendig um nachahmer das machen
aber der zusammenhalt den kranz kaufmann
lager das schnaufen computer miteinander
oder
ganz einfach ich zwar nichts kommt erst
mal her im trocknen ist daher eine
völlige gewertet und habe richtig oder
ist dieser prozess muss besprochen
vom namen her zusammensitzen
marcel vermietet und verkauft anhänger
transport und handel nennt er seine
firma
weil sein unternehmen noch in den
startlöchern steckt arbeitet er auch
noch als lastwagenchauffeur
harmlosen die jetzt da sind
ja nicht auf hilfe hoffen polar sind die
importiert wurde das heißt die
spannung vor der russische krankheit
haben wir den sack mit einem kurz nach
das dann muss ich sagen das problem also
man muss wirklich sagen dass es
funktioniert dass ich über die sachen ja
wenn man gesehen
was hat das alles mit dem eigenen sack
kann ich das
finanzielle risiko gegangen meint das
system andererseits weniger es sei
sowohl ein verkauf verdienen johann
gerät ja nicht schon bereits eine frau
folgen und jetzt da er daher dass ich
eine option gekauft da ich jetzt
nächsten tag musste auf controller aber
der hat ja bereits
ja also
für mich jetzt der könig statt 27
ja und ich bin direkt frieden zwischen
skoda gelaufen was ein richtiger
business mode ja ich hoffe das ist das
eigentlich wirkt
[Musik]
die situation ist nicht besser geworden
bei silvia und stefan f der konkurs des
hofes oberhalb von ruswil löste bei ihm
eine depression aus mehrere wochen
verbrachte der 27 jährige in einer
psychiatrischen klinik vor wenigen tagen
ist er wieder zu seiner familie
zurückgekehrt
[Musik]
ich war wieder in ruhigen entspannten
ist eine sache
ja
schön um es nimmt
stefan muss sich aber noch schonen und
unnötige belastungen vermeiden so lässt
er an diesem tag silvia allein ziehen
sie geht an die versteigerung der kühe
der anlass findet im luzernischen kunst
wien statt
120 milchkühe von stefan und sylvia
werden versteigert vom erlös sehen die
beiden nichts hier fliesst
vollumfänglich in die konkursmasse ein
[Musik]
muss ich meine rente starten
überzeugende musik dauert heute
musikfreunde sind versuchen sie redet
franz gruber der nation der deutschlands
vorinstanz grunde zeit wurden die 25 20
15 13 würfen
tanzsportzentrums vor
bedauerlich ruhr zentrum besteht mit dem
flug zum ersten
sich das gesetz in kraft seien es 101 zu
betrachten 82 28 wirklich komponisten
zum zweiten und zum dritten
das ist gültig
der ganze bestand konnte vermarktet
werden nun heißt es abschied nehmen das
ende eines weiteren bauern betriebs
ja das ist mir
bis vor ein paar minuten gar das ist ja
das ist ja ganz so gab
es aus basel ab
[Musik]
im akw nimmt alles seinen gewohnten lauf
selbst körper sagt ihm schon lange dass
er kürzer treten muss aber noch hat er
keine lösung gefunden um sein bauerngut
zu retten deshalb macht er weiter trotz
versteiften sprunggelenken und prothesen
mit seinem eigenen schicksal kann er gut
umgehen was ihn aber bekümmert sind
silvias und stefans probleme
also ich meine wenn der junge
problem hat das ist nicht schön und das
ist ja
doch dank manchmal
darüber nach was man da machen kann oder
ob es im nachruf von einem techniker
körper
doch insgeheim hat sich der 66 jährige
bereits eine lösung ausgedacht eine die
auch ihm entgegenkommen würde schon
lange möchte selbst einen betrieb an die
nächste generation übergeben
der nur langsame bisherige prämie
geister durch auf von erlebnis machen
aber er hat möglichst vielen zähler und
steht von
hat das ja schon seit bismarck und dass
ich eigentlich sicher
im land
[Musik]
es ist still geworden so ganz ohne tiere
im gehöft oberhalb von ruswil
doch da trübsinn herrscht
aufbruchstimmung silvia und stefan haben
mit über die hof übernahme geredet die
beiden wollen nun in sach ali ziehen was
hat dann jetzt zu dem sie nichts sagen
für ziel wie das griechische überlegt
sachlich zu übernehmen
ja das sind es doch wer also danke der
wichtigste faktor ist sicher mit
perspektivenlosigkeit womit hängt also
der stefan hätte jobs gesucht und nicht
gefunden und ich bin zieht ferien mit
liefer umschulungsmaßnahmen daran dass
gott und gar nicht vorwärts also ich
heute
hier
sind jetzt glücklich mit der lösung
hat
sich ja immer sie trank sie wird immer
nur da zwar
unterstütze
funktioniert
für mich ist die sache ja ich meine ich
habe das immer also ich meine sind die
mini wurzel hof immer gern kommt die ja
und august wurden sind
[Musik]
eine hürde muss noch genommen werden sie
als geschwister müssen sich der hof
übernahme einverstanden sein
maria lebt seit ein paar monaten eine
neue stelle
die 29 jährige arbeitet in schwyz als
kader frau in einem restaurant
13 mitarbeitende führt sie diese mussten
sich zuerst einmal an den frischen wind
gewöhnen den sie in den betrieb brachte
mittlerweile
bauen und und und das ziemlich ein team
zusammen eigentlich ja wort umsätze
stets zögerte sie den betrieb ihres
vaters zu übernehmen das nun silvia und
stefan in sach ali einziehen möchten
findet die gelernte bäuerin keine gute
lösung die beiden sei nicht in der lage
den hof erfolgreich zu führen glaubt
marian zudem befürchtet sie ihre heimat
zu verlieren deshalb sachlich für mich
immer der sicherste ort sie also
wenigstens schlusszeit gewiss wenn ich
wenn alles bach abgaben
666 im labertal nämlich eine sache
zurück und sage ich immer dass ich an ob
sie wie wäre es also wenn ich mit meiner
familie hätte oder und wenn es das
bachab gott da habe ich jetzt gewiss
gefühl als partner noch teil oder und
weil ich ja das klappt ja
[Musik]
im ak league kommt es anfang dezember zu
einer aussprache
die familie bespricht die zukunft des
hofes
[Musik]
findet und finde da gehört dass du hier
ist über den hinterhöfen stunde hüffer
jahr schaffen ich finde es schade wenn
wir das jetzt eigentlich der wahre plage
ja wenn man es eigentlich schenk dir
halt und ich meine es gibt keine
garantie dass das funktioniert ich es
gibt für mich im rahmen einer garantie
ich denke aus meiner sicht natürlich
nicht die ferien und ich habe mich
nachhaltig mittwoch hat es
wahrscheinlich zeit dass das sehr sehr
schwierige sache
mit dem mitmieter im betrieb mit mit
einer enorm für die direktzahlungen mit
der familie dazu ich war daher näher das
ist völlig bewusst aber so dass man also
riss einen krater der sich mit wird
nachhaltig ist das spiel aber ich finde
mich aus aber ich ließ also zu
pessimistisch ziemlich wenig ich bin
pessimistisch ich sehe einfach was was
ich sehe heute wo a haltige mit ihren
sorgen
ich meine ich meine eigene theoretisch
ist dass wir wenn du den oberst robert
und alles wichtig und so meine ich
heute die letzte also und ich freue mich
dass ich dass man das nur das ja nehmen
dass sich die leute ja
nicht sagen i blicke studie
zwischen
vorher jetzt ausgang und sammer stehe
ich an land verpachten und habe mit ihm
gemacht dass ich einigermaßen
stand sondern schnitt gar nicht auch die
das schädliche gas
gmbh dass man als bisher also das ist ja
nun mal wenn man
wie ich wollte sich mit dem heimatfilm
entwickelt über den besten weg um acht
uhr
maximal sind
widersprüche beim heime und bei allem
aber es sind sich reilly thoma wo wohin
dies stand und wo ist sein erstes mini
täglich stellen es ist einfach so wenn
man sie drängt die abgang und aber nur
jeder sein eigener kraft heute am trikot
von sich aus gerne gemacht eine freude
machen beschloss allerdings ist es der
iran hof und besorge dass er irgendwer
schlug der
richtige da müssen sich die erste heim
weissenau
auch wenn ford seine machen nur wenn
jetzt das sage ich
willkommen hieß und ja
wie ich habe mich das ist ja ich habe
ich noch nicht aber es dafür für euch
also ich habe sich in der sache gemacht
ja
also ich
kann die chance aber
und die meiner als ich mit achtjähriger
sohn
[Musik]
es ist ein frostiger tag und doch voller
hoffnung
selbst nachfolger ziehen in den kleinen
hof oberhalb von dresden ein silvia und
stefan app sind die fünfte generation im
familienbetrieb
[Musik]
das ärgert wissen tut es auch anerkannt
aber
hochpolitisch stüber
stüber
nur marcel hilft den beiden beim einzug
alle anderen geschwister zeigen sich an
diesem tag nicht sie glauben dass silvia
und stefan die neue aufgabe
unterschätzen
ich meine spieler hilft was ich weiß was
es heißt herz bührer und ich bin ich
wenn man sich gut organisiert haben wir
hier eine existenz nur der takeda fährt
hinterher groß ca
und wie ich sollte mit löse ich das
jetzt sehen wir unter stefan übernommen
für mich ist wichtig aus als ein risiko
eigentlich also
sorgen
stets ging die familie gemeinsam durch
dick und dünn nun ist sie gespalten
vor allem marian ist verärgert
[Musik]
aber sie hat sich keiner dafür
entscheide
hundertprozentig meine sich anita
mehrere zur vorwurf machen machen werden
sie sich nicht keine entscheide sie hat
farben in der hand kauf sie hat keiner
sage ich niemals unterwegs habe ich in
irgendeiner vorwurf gemacht
also einfacher als auch die
auswahl der mann dahinter nehmen wir das
thema und
das
selbst wer mit seiner lebenspartnerin
maria und tochter julia nach preston
ziehen
alle alten möbel müssen raus auch der
küchentisch
um ihn herum versammelte sich
jahrzehntelang die familie
die autorin forderte
übernehmen
wir
machen
das kommt das schulde gott
das ist positiv denken und danach das
wort
und so endet diese geschichte mit einem
neuanfang
viele jahre lang hat die familie app um
eine lösung gerungen
jetzt ist sie da
aber der schatten über dem 8 der bleibt
[Musik]
[Applaus]